Maximilian Robespierre promised you Asha,
a fairer,
more representative form of government to the French people.
What they got instead was a reign of terror that saw thousands facing the horror
of the guillotine.
Among his victims were the king and Queen of France.
When justice finally came,
it was a swift as the slice of a blade in this week,
spire graphics.
We Wade into the terror with a biography of Maximilian Robespierre Maximilian
Robespierre
ends of the world on May the sixth 1758 he was born and harass froms.
Historians have suspected for centuries that is family originated from Ireland.
By the time the Max was born,
though they had been at French citizens for many generations.
The child was conceived out of wedlock,
but by the time he was born,
his parents had gotten married like his own father before him.
Max.
His father was a lawyer,
but not for a very successful one.
This left the family with a constant desks hanging over their heads.
Things didn't get any easier for the rubber SBE as when Max,
his mother died,
giving birth to a sibling when he was only six years old.
Looking after four children was too much for Robert sps seniors,
so his offspring were divided among his relatives.
His mother's death had a profound impact upon the young Max.
No longer was he the carefree child of old.
Now.
He was Sullen and he was serious.
He also applied himself diligently to his schooling as if he was drowning his
grief with his studies.
When he was 11 years of age,
young Robespierre was awarded a scholarship to the least see Louie la grounds in
Paris.
He would continue studying there for the next 12 years emerging at age 23 with a
law degree as well as law.
He also studied literature or rhetoric and the classics life at the prestigious
school.
It was very structured,
formerly a Jesuit institution.
There was now under the control of the University of Paris.
The day began and ended with formal prayers and Bible study.
The school also has an excellent library,
which Robespierre made liberal use of the most well known incidents arising from
Robespierre is time at the school of cards when he was 17 his excellence oratory
skills led them to being selected to give a speech before King Louis the 16th
and Queen Marie Antoinette.
He perfected his wording and practices delivery only to be snubbed by the role
couple who never even bothered to get out of the carriage.
It was a personal violation and one that he would never forget during his time
of the light.
Sear Robespierre was also exposed to enlightenment philosophy,
especially the works of Jacques Rousseau.
Rousseau was powerful advocates for a more democratic form of government coupled
with social empowerment's.
However,
Maximilian was not able to read Rousseau in the library of the school.
His works were considered to be dangerous and so copies of his famous discourse
published 20 years earlier had to be smuggled in in his later life.
Robespierre would label his later years of the lacy as a nursery for
republicanism.
By the time he had reached his early twenties Robespierre was a vocal advocate
for natural rights.
He champions the rights of the underprivileged speaking as every opportunity.
In fact,
he was such an enthusiastic champion of basic human rights that he became
physically exhausted to the point of collapse.
Robespierre proved to be an unstoppable force of nature.
This led to him becoming a familiar as well known figure in and around his
hometown.
In the mid seventies and eighties he joined the academy a verace.
His first speech before the academy was part of a competition and Sean a
spotlight upon the lack of morality and politics.
It didn't win first prize,
but he was rewarded with a large cash prize.
This wet his appetites and over the next few years he ended a number of essay
and poetry competitions.
He also joins and elites literary society known as the Receiver Year Club.
Since his graduation with a degree in law,
Robespierre had established a moderate practice from the very start.
He began taking on cases that were controversial in 1789 he took on the state in
a case that directly challenged the notion of lead tray to cache or imprisonment
without trial.
During the trial.
He actually wrote to the king and personally requested his assistance in getting
rid of this abuse.
By the seventies and eighties France was desperately running out of money.
They had spent a lot of money and assisting the Americans in the previous
decade.
This was compounded by a lavish amount of spending on the part of the monarchy,
VA appointments of a succession of finance.
Ministers do try and turn arounds.
The country's economy has little effects.
By the end of the decade,
there was a growing call for a meeting of the estates general representing the
clergy,
the inability and the people.
Meanwhile,
the king unilaterally enacted a series of laws to fill the royal coffers.
This included the raising of taxes and the cutting of spending on essential
services.
The following day,
the French parliament condemns the king's actions labeling the raising of taxes
as illegal.
The king's response where stu simply exile the parliaments.
This,
as you might expect to lead,
do growing protests in Paris.
In response to this desperate situation,
a new finance minister was put in place.
This minister,
it was [inaudible].
He proposed a new five year plan,
which was designed to restore French credit as well as presenting a full
accounting of the French government's finances to whoever wanted to see it.
He called for the return of the Parisians parliaments after their normal autumn
break.
The parliaments reconvenes November the 17th 1787 in the rare presence of the
king.
After an eight hour debates,
the parliament failed to authorize brands five year plan.
However it King Louis the 16th went ahead and authorize the loans that were
needed to restore credit.
Anyway,
the king left the chamber,
but the debate continued.
It was resolved that the parliament would officially condemn the king's actions.
The following day.
The leading members of parliaments were exiled by the king and response to this
provincial parliaments across the country began to refuse to register laws as a
protest to the apparently does spotting actions if the king on May the third
1788 the parliaments of Paris issued a declaration on the fundamental laws of
the realm is included.
The rise of parliaments who registered new laws,
the role of the estates General Lens,
the freedom of all subjects from arbitrary arrest.
Despite this,
the leaders of the parliaments,
they were taken into custody and lead the following day.
A few days later,
the king issued a series of judicial reforms which were designed to to cement
his absolute power.
The reforms effectively neutralized the parliaments of Paris in response to this
outrage prevents your parliaments around the country refuse to uphold any of the
government's laws.
France was now operating without any formal justice system.
The country was approaching widespread public revolts and then attempts to
control the damage.
Finance Minister Brianne calls for a sitting of the estates general on May the
first 1789 meanwhile,
the French government was complete the bankrupt with no ideas to get the country
out of the red.
Brianne was forced to resign and former finance minister Jack Neck was put back
in office and the general confidence of the people and managed to recall the
parliaments around the country.
The Paris parliaments announced that the estates general would meet according to
the historic precedent where the representation of the people,
the third estate would be numerically less than that of the clergy and the
nobility.
This was something that was met with widespread public disapproval,
three long negotiations with the king.
Okay.
I was able to announce in December of 1788 that the representation of the third
estate would be doubled and the estates general.
Meanwhile,
hundreds of pamphlets had been appearing around Paris with titles such as what
is the third estate rather than being comprised of peasants,
workers or artisans.
The third estate was made up of lawyers and office holders,
the well to do who had enough time to engage in the Slo process involved.
The pamphlet is strongly criticized the power of the clergy and the nobility and
the lack of representation of the masses.
Several leaders arose among the third estate and that included Maximilian
Robespierre.
By 1788 Robespierre was positioning himself to play a key role in the coming
revolution.
He participated a series of debates regarding the makeup of the third estate and
the ratio of the three components of the estates general.
He published a pamphlet which address local issues and arrest with the view of
getting himself elected onto the third estate and the pamphlets.
He strongly stressed.
Two key ideas,
the importance of elected representation and they concern for the poor.
By now,
Robert [inaudible] has a clearly defined notion of who the enemy was and that
was the clergy and the nobility.
In March of 1789 he was elected as a representative from our ass to the third
estate.
He was chosen to participate in the drafting of a list of grievances.
At the same time,
he pushed for new incentives that would give the lower classes access to the
political system.
Robespierre is seconds.
Pamphlet was a foretaste of things to come.
It was called the enemies of the country on masked
the estates.
General mats on the 5th of May,
[inaudible] 1789 at first sight,
30 year old robbers spear was one of eight representatives from a wraps and the
formal opening of proceedings.
He and his fellow third estate members refused to now before the king.
That first day Robespierre,
he began to stand out.
He was not an imposing physical figure and his voice was less than inspiring,
but he dressed impeccably and had an amazing ability to recall details.
He customarily wore a powdered wig and they formal waistcoat.
In the first week of the assembly,
he forms a breakaway group known as the Breton Club,
which held their own meetings to discuss the abolition of the privileges of the
clergy and the nobility.
On June the seventh Robespierre gave a passionate speech criticizing the
excesses of the clergy.
It was one of the major motivators for the establishment of the National
Assembly.
Three days later on [inaudible],
the third estate sent messages to the clergy and nobility requesting that they
agree to common verification by headcounts are receiving no response.
They declared themselves the only legitimate representative body renaming
themselves the comments.
The public received this news with great enthusiasm.
Eventually the clergy under much public pressure joins the National Assembly on
the morning of June the 20th at the National Assembly turns up to their meeting
place.
Of a sign to find the gate's locked sins.
The entrance man's by guards.
They quickly retreated to a nearby tennis courts on the grounds of a side.
The members were enraged at the desk.
Pot isn't of the king and shutting out the National Assembly.
They unanimously asserted what has become known as the tennis court oath.
They vowed to remain in session until the constitution of the realm and public
regeneration are established and assured.
On June the 17th the king opens the role session.
His first move was to declare the National Assembly and valid.
He then put forward a 35 point plan for reform.
His final move was to announce this.
Nothing that the estates general did was valid without his personal consent.
Yeah.
Once the king had dismissed the assembly,
the nobility and clerics filed out,
but the members of the National Assembly comprising the third estate and the
clergy remained where they were.
It was declared that they would only leave at the end of bear nets with the
entire country in support of the National Assembly.
The king,
he backed down.
He owns it the first and second to states to join the National Assembly.
Still the riots.
They did not end Louis send troops to surrounds the city of Paris,
the National Assembly,
and now I've got to work and hammered out a list of demands to be the king.
Robespierre was one of those who presented them with the first one being that he
removed the trips,
the king.
He ignored the demands.
By the beginning of July,
there were 20,000 soldiers around the city.
Robespierre responded by making a public statement.
No one loves the arms missionaries.
The first lesson of nature and it's prudence,
is to repulse them as necessary.
And so it proved to be on July the 11th the king dismissed finance minister neck
out who was still publicly popular.
This led to rage among the people.
A few days later,
rumors spread like wildfire that the French army was a bouncer launch from
attack on the people and mobs of citizens reacted to the impending days by
seizing at 28,000 rifles from a veteran's hospital.
They now needed gunpowder to use them,
and as they found it,
it's an unused prison in the city called the bass steel.
The guards tried to hold off the crowds,
but then fired into the hundreds of people fell down debt the now out of control
and mob overpowered and killed the guards and then gained access to the gun
powder.
When the king sent soldiers to bring order,
they switched loyalties and they've joined the people.
Louie now new particular trust.
No one,
not even it's protective army.
Meanwhile,
the National Assembly,
they remained in session in a desperate attempt to restore order the king
reappointed neck out,
but the finance minister refuse to work with the National Assembly and was
unable to stem the flow of rebellion.
I'm July the 19th he king road through Paris and a carriage along with key
members of the national assembly including Robert Spi APP.
Rather than crying hours long live the king,
the people called out long live liberty long live the nation.
Let me try to play,
keep the crowns by telling them that he had ordered the troops to withdraw the
$150,000 citizens who flooded the streets,
took it as too little too late.
Though across the country,
armed mobs were taking to the streets with many of them seizing control of their
city governments.
Starving people broke into grand juries and the estates of their landlords
helping themselves to food and provisions while other members of the National
Assembly express concern that the growing chaos Robespierre saw insurrection as
the national expression of the People's.
Well,
it was those who opposed revolution who are actually the real threat.
He became fanatical in his results.
He,
we doubt any and all who shaped dissent to the apparent well of the people.
Meanwhile,
the National Assembly began working on a new constitution,
the declaration of the rights of man and the citizen was voted on August the
26th the king didn't respond to the declaration in till October,
by which time the riots in the streets were still ongoing.
He expressed concerns at a number of the articles in the declaration.
At the same time,
he called the Alif Flanders Regimen to society,
provide extra protection.
On the morning of October the fifth a large group of market women marched on
velocity,
demand flour and grain.
They were met at the gates by Robert's pm who while showing empathy for their
situation,
advised caution.
He managed to negotiate for a single woman to meet the king lear.
We agreed to allow the release of two stores of grain,
but again,
for Louis it was too little too late.
By evening,
a massive crowd had gathered at Versailles.
Many of the moms,
they lingered throughout the night.
Then early on,
the morning of October the sixth a group of them managed to break in to the
queen's bedroom.
Meridian managed to escape,
but to have her gods were killed,
but there were a couple were forced to leave the palace and seek refuge in an
unused palace in Paris,
the Erie,
they will follow that by a crowd of 60,000 people.
The king and queen spend the next few months as virtual prisoners in the palace
power rested with the National Assembly among Ridge Rubbers.
P has influence with having more prominence over the next year.
The assembly works towards a constitutional monarchy.
In June of 1791 the king had had enough along with his wife.
He disguised himself as a servant and fledge in the carriage.
He left behind the documents which clearly denounced the national assembly.
The carriage journey got 160 miles outside of Paris and then they were taken
back to the palace.
Yeah.
The night after the king's attempts to flee the country,
Robespierre gave an impassioned speech in which he stated that the deadliest
enemies of the French when the Austrians,
he threatened war but counter revolutionary forces within France itself.
He also said that the king should be counted as one of those enemies of the
nation.
This speech,
it broke the assembly into on the one side,
there were those who clung to the idea of a constitutional monarchy.
Well,
those who sided with Robespierre,
we're in favor of republicanism.
Robespierre.
He began to call for the public trial of the king on July.
The 17th or group of petitioners who supported the call were confronted by the
national guardsmen and the melee that followed 50 of them were killed.
The French constitution was completed in September of 1791 effectively putting
an end to the work of the assembly.
Robespierre resent to harass where he was welcomed as a hero of the people.
Meanwhile,
the king had declared war on Austria.
Robespierre spoke out against the war stating that it was not in the interests
of the people and he feared that it would galvanize them around the king and
thus destroy the revolution.
During the spring of 1792 there were vocal calls for the creation of a French
republic.
Robespierre,
however,
had changed his tune and was now in favor of a constitutional monarchy.
However,
when a large protest outside between early on,
the third anniversary of the tennis court,
oath turns nasty.
He found himself in a standoff with the kings key enforcer,
General Lafayette,
who stood ready to put down the marches with force protests at the tweeter.
He continued culminating in the king and queen being forced to flee and seek
protection from the National Assembly.
More than a thousand people were killed that night and it's way the monarchy was
officially dissolved in the royal family were taken into custody as prisoners of
the state.
Following these events,
Robert's be app was elected to the insurrection commune,
which was the governing body which now kept order in Paris.
He oversaw a period of interrogation of royalists for a raft of suspected crimes
against the state.
Many of these royalists prisoners were pulled from their prison cells by mobs
and simply massacred.
This is where I'm simply handed to eventual mob is after mock trials in the
first week of September,
1970 to around 1,400 people were killed by these mobs.
Robespierre insisted the commune also investigate counter revolutionary
activities so it would condemned 28 people to death by the heading.
In the midst of this carnage,
elections were held for a new constitutional assembly.
Rubber spear was elected as a first deputy.
Still there where those within the assemblies that's rejected to his violent
methods of enforcements through force or arguments here sidelines than winning
the day with his conviction that the ends justified the means,
no matter how violent the means may be the trial of the king.
I'll have again on December the 26th 1792 three weeks later,
he was found unanimously guilty.
Robespierre himself sums up the will of the Times.
It is where the regrets that I must pronounce the fatal truth that King must die
so that the country may live.
France executed it's king.
On January the 21st 1793 Robespierre he did not attend to the occasion.
On July the 20th 1793 Robespierre was elected to the committee of public safety,
which had been established just a few months earlier.
The committee began to take action against federalist revolutionists.
Mass executions were ordered in Leo,
which was a hotbed of royalists sympathy.
Revolts were breaking out all over leading the convention to declare terror.
The order of the day on September the 17th they pass laws,
allowing them to put to death.
Anyone who was implicated as a supporter of tyranny caught up in the net of the
reign of terror was Marie Antoinette's.
After a sham trial,
she was sent to the guillotine on October the 16th 1793 Robespierre.
He now set his sights on his former National Assembly,
opposes the girder nests.
They were do you need tried and found guilty and sent to the Guillotine?
Controlling all of these executions was rubbers Pierre,
who famously declared to punish the oppressors of humanity is clemency to
forgive them is barbarity.
Those who were opposed Robespierre in the assembly found themselves facing the
guillotine.
Before long he had absolute power within the committee.
He had become a virtual dictator literally with the power of life and death in
his hands along with his immense power.
Robespierre grew increasingly paranoid.
Then there was an attempt on his life in May of 1793 the following month he was
elected president of the convention.
He immediately enacted changes to allow him to condemn even more people to
death.
[inaudible] were reduced to mere condemnations and all accused were denied legal
representation.
He even created a new category of criminal gold enemy of the people.
This blanket term could cover anything from serving sour wine.
Do sending a letter to England.
Yeah,
it's the punishments.
It was always the same death by guillotine.
By this time,
Robespierre had gone too far.
The people were beginning to reject his despotic rule of terror.
His political enemies orchestrator,
they falsified lesser,
which appeared to implicate Robespierre and an attempted coup to Tom.
He defended himself against charges of dictatorship in a two hour speech.
In this speech,
she warned of a conspiracy that was being hatched against the republic,
but it was all to no avail.
The next day he was arrested or needs to be freed.
Shortly thereafter,
like trips from the Paris commune,
Robert's Vn and his defenders found themselves hold up at the Hotel de Ville.
They were declared outlaws by the convention,
which means that when course they could be put to death immediately when the
convention forces closed in on the hotel rather SBM,
and as those who were with him all tried to commit suicide,
some of them succeeded,
but Robespierre has attempts to blow out.
His brain's only managed to shatter his lower jaw with blondes pouring from his
face.
Robespierre was laid on the table in the room of the committee for public safety
before being transferred to the cell that is housed Maria,
and it's going to ask prior to her date with a guillotine,
the end game for Robespierre on July the 28th 1794 when he became the final
victim of his reign of terror,
seconds before the blade fell,
the executioner ripped off the bandage that keeping his jaw together,
causing him to let out an all mighty scream.
It was soon silenced by the deadly blade.
Finally ending the carnage that Robespierre has warped view of justice had
wrought.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the race,
and as always,
thank you for watching.
Okay.